I can pinch fresh 445 pounds
I could flip 270 pound tire
I could even handstand push-ups and I
can climb a rope act look damn good
doing it I'm Zack rule and adaptive
crossfitter and a power lifter I was
born with the deformity and pretty much
my legs looked real messed up so I would
never be able to walk use them so they
made a decision to get them amputated
I've been amputee double amputee since I
was two years old partnership with
Fitness started out in high school I
just started lifting weights like
anybody else and I always always did it
for appearance at first if I'm just
gonna be a torso I'm gonna be one damn
looking good torso and then it just took
over my life like I want to know
everything there is no about the anatomy
of the human body how to get stronger
what creates muscle growth like I was a
sponge I've been told I can't bench
press more than 400 pounds my ass I've
been told I wouldn't have a gym my own
my biggest motivation in life is people
tell me I can't do something for free
classes or free personal training to
adaptive athletes or people with
disabilities so I have a girl with
cerebral palsy of a girl that has a
spinal cord injury and I have another
quadruple amputee that I'm personal
training right now CrossFit has done so
much for my life and I feel like I just
want to pass that on and show everybody
that it is possible you can work past
disabilities and wherever your goals are
especially fitness wise you can meet
them it's just going to be a little bit
different route than somebody else
I am Ernestine shepherd 80 years of age
i benchpress 110 pounds I started
training at age 71 I was named the
oldest female competitive bodybuilder
and two Guinness Book of World Records
my sister and I started exercising
together I had never done any type of
exercising before before she died she
said promise me you will follow my dream
and try to get in the Guinness Book of
World Records so that's what I did
[Music]
I have been in six or seven competitions
I win but some I come out second and
third and I'm pleased with that
[Music]
I'm up every morning at 2:30 after I
have my devotions I walk in I run
approximately ten miles I'm at the gym
at 7:30 and I have a group of ladies
that I trained
I've trained all ages one of the
youngest I think she's about 20 years of
age and the rest go from 40 all the way
up to 80
when people come to my class for the
very first time they are really really
surprised they said I didn't think this
exercise would be this tough but if you
can do it we are going to do it too
[Music]
I really don't feel as though I'm 80
years of age but I am I want to keep
training until my day is done pull your
shoulder blades back together there you
go
by believing and doing it excited at the
gym is really keeping me alive okay
three more yeah correct if I was to
start working out at the gym I love
house the dead by now okay my name is
Wayne McCray Washington and I'm a
professional bodybuilder I don't know
you could seek him a hand moving Oh a
diagnosed with throat palsy maybe 11
months
you know I got off with scoliosis at the
age of 12 when I first went to doctor
they had told me that I was not gonna
live through fetal weight and I have
been friends here at the gym I'm his
personal trainer yes and he approached
me with a very serious tone and he told
me that he wants to do a bodybuilding
show you know one of my goals worked
nearby ability the other one was a
perfect no wrestler but the wrestling
with too dangerous
in the beginning he didn't have the
control to get on a machine and just
work the body parts that we were
intending to work his hands and his feet
need to be stabilized you in yeah all
right so I got very creative and I built
up you know apparatuses that would fit
him in order for him to secure himself
and actually pull with the muscles that
I was wanting him to do up up instead of
it telling me what to do you're telling
when to do you so let's tell it what to
do again okay okay
the way I approach everything every time
I train I have to focus a lot harder
a lot more of Woodbury Park they don't
work it over to make it work right for
me and has improved a lot
the basic happiness that comes from
feeling strong and feeling able instead
of disabled is a big deal Mumbai has got
a lot failure I have people tell me
their own taller um every state steel
well but it's called team Wade
accomplished his pro status as a
bodybuilder was the most unbelievable
experience this was something no one
ever thought could happen and it
happened we made this happen different
amazing and I'm blessed to hell a cousin
idea or friend I Tina I enjoy being a
problem and bigger
it's my lifestyle now my parents said I
could be anything so I became guy and
when I'm up on stage I feel like this is
actually Who I am
[Music]
my name is Preston Thomas Martin and I'm
a bodybuilder the trans bodybuilding
competition is a bodybuilding
competition for trans men who are pre or
post stop for their Top surgery
it's basically like a comfortable
setting that we can all come to those of
us who love fitness this is the third
year of the competition and it's grown a
lot since they first started there's
more competitors there's more people
that are coming out to see it it's just
growing bigger and bigger I've always
watched the national professional
bodybuilders up on stage and I'm just
like oh man like I want to be there one
day and this trans bodybuilding
competition has done that for trans
people this is a comfortable setting for
me to do something that I love to do and
show off I came to like bodybuilding
because I realized that it helped me a
lot as far as my mental health goals
bodybuilding is like therapy for me it
helps me learn how to calm myself it
makes you a stronger person all the way
around after transitioning my
perspective on masculinity has changed a
lot even though it's been six years
since I've been transitioning I am still
a sweetheart
when I look in the mirror now I see a
strong person but I have really had to
look at my life and everything that I
have accomplished and everything that I
have been through and being able to come
back from the fact that I am happy with
my transition I'm happy with the way
that I'm turning out in the way I'm
looking I'm happy with how strong I'm
becoming mentally I look at her and I
can't help but smile I get excited
[Music]
it's okay to be different it's okay to
not look like a normal person it's okay
to get outside your comfort zone and be
courageous even if people don't like it
along this positive then you should
press forward with it my name is Isaiah
Griffin and I'm a bodybuilder when I was
1718 I developed this condition called
keloids basically they wanted your body
over heals itself started as bumps every
now and then that will burst open that
look like regular acne then they started
to just connect and make the web
basically on my chest in earlier stages
of having my keloids honestly didn't
understand it or how to feel about it I
wasn't in a mirror so much there won't
be times where I would just wash my face
turn the lights off
mentally mess with my confidence I had a
depression from it but mainly weren't
about focus on what other people think
kind of been an issue but slowly but
surely I just started wearing a tank
tops in a gym to where I feel like I'm
overcoming whatever is peddling on
outside or inside there was something
new something completely different I
want to work towards being a world
champion but this journey is more about
self-improvement more than it is
receiving any medals anything being a
champion it is nice but I need to see
the real meaning what I'm doing when I
see myself in the mirror now just see
myself and love myself all the past the
scars and just see a person who doesn't
want to accept the norm it's African
proverb if there's no enemy within the
enemy outside can do us no harm
[Music]